well the monthly meeting of the injured
police officers fund was held today
facta
it was the first time since metro lost
lieutenant eric lloyd to covet 19.
today's events included a check
presentation and also beginning
discussions on how to move forward
after the loss of lieutenant lloyd the
ipof
appointed a new president today and
lloyd's wife was there as well
in her position of project director and
she talked about the
why when it comes to officers continuing
to do their jobs in the face of a
pandemic
the organization itself and the brothers
and sisters and
in blue they have been amazing
and they continue the work that they
that they feel in their heart because
they they know that they have families
too
and it could be them i just
know i have huge shoes to fill eric was
a great man he had a huge heart
and such a big passion for this position
and he didn't care what his title was he
did everything that he could to support
our mission at the injured police
officers fund to help those in need
the fund focuses now on covid prevention
raising awareness
and also getting the message out and
working to be more vocal about the
reality of the pandemic